the third round of negotiations has ended,
we will wipe the pancakes results for you,
from the point of view of the
logistics of the humanitarian corridors, it
will be treasonable to them, and now they directly
killed their active help to people and
today the potter memory is because of the aggression of the
Russian square from the point of zuru of the
key political track where
these quixote  obstacles are not outside and reconciliation and in the
law of ending hostilities,
intensive consultations will
continue today, as a result, in the kitty
body, shake the situation with the kidnapped, and you
give me less consultation again under the
cross and will be continued by him directly, and the
result for today was a long discussion of the
problem of humanitarian corridors about
which  agreed at the last meeting,
but which did not work at all on the
reason for the non-fulfillment by the Ukrainian
armed forces on the ground of the
order of the command and
their administration, we
raised the issue of riza point-blank, we don’t really
understand how to explain it, but we hope
that starting tomorrow these corridors will
finally work in
Ukraine  The Indian side gave us its
assurances of this, we arrived with a large set of
written documents, we have already taken
specific agreements,
drafts and proposals
and hoped that today it would be possible in principle to sign at least a protocol for those
pounds on which it seems that we have already
agreed,
however, the
Ukrainian side all these documents
I took it for study, I will honestly say that
our expectations of the negotiations
did not come true, but we hope that
next time I will be able to take a more
significant step forward, the
negotiations will indeed be
quickly continued, we will not indulge ourselves in the
illusion that the final result will be reached on the next step after the
step will
be quite difficult and
consistent  Job